it's reckless it's clever the blighters
control every criminal enterprise in the
city if they work for us yes but they
work for the Templars they paid off by
the Templars like difference if we take
control of the gangs retake control of
London from the bottom up you are
talking about building yourself an army
with FRA delemus is complete madness
you'd need to consolidate your control I
can keep the rival gangs and the police
from sweeping in and seizing the
territory can't very well send bloody
Nora an engraved invitation we have no
idea where they holed up
yeah we do you found them the Black Keys
are operating out there we agree why do
you know we'll be there good work Clara
tremendous work Jacob can't talk now
Henry duty calls
to your health my apologies mr. green
hey guys this is Jeremy Jane from
GameSpot calm I was lucky enough today
to have the opportunity to take a look
at Assassin's Creed syndicate III 2015
gameplay demo and I have to say as
somebody who hasn't really been a huge
fan of the series for the last few
iterations I was still extremely
impressed the combat was quick crisp
satisfying and intuitive the traversal
was much improved with the addition of
the grapple shot which allows you to get
up and over buildings quickly without
the hassle of going window ledge to
window ledge and overall I just have to
say that I really enjoyed this demo I'm
not going to talk over the rest of it
just so you guys can check it out in its
full glory but thanks for watching and
stay tuned a game spot for more III 2015
coverage
of course no one can see
huh
well well your statins are come crawling
out there rose up they damn it boys deal
with it
steady on
yeah
yeah
ah
you
let them know what you can do
ladies and gentlemen we are jacob and
evie frye
and as of this moment you all work for
us
you